muito boa noite a todos é obrigado por
estarem aqui presentes e abriga também
pelo convite é de hoje vem de fora mas
não pare de destruir as estrelas e da
evolução tecnológica que nos permitiu
chegar é hoje o ponto que vocês vão
perceber é que chegamos eu vou começar
com uma imagem que é da galaxie landau é
a luz que chega hoje em dia desta
galáxia foi projetado após passar cerca
de 2,5 milhões de anos atrás altura em
que a terra é preciso pela primeira vez
é o gênero homo fria a origem mais tarde
a nossa espécie nos casar
o homem mais desenvolvido aumento ao
homem moderno
neste caso esta fotografia que vocês
viram atrás foi captada em 1825 como os
copos grande uma longa exposição de 90
minutos mas hoje em dia infelizmente
graças à tecnologia com uma câmera
destas uma câmera reflex uma
teleobjetiva é e montagem montagem quina
cabe na palma da mão
dessas 700 gramas e tanto muito
diferente daquelas montagens e normas
que antigamente os astrônomos tinham
acesso para tentar fotografar o
firmamento e esta foto vocês vão ver
quem está deste ano é forte da galáxia
de andrômeda onde é possível ver todo o
tempo a coroa todo detalhe é desta
galáxia vizinha da nossa via láctea mas
na realidade é outros objetos que também
podem ver e que podem observar neste
caso um exemplo aquela imagem peregrina
foi captada também em 1880 e foi foram
feitas
foi uma longa exposição de cerca de 135
3 137 minutos para conseguir captar é
aquela criança nebulosidade
como vocês podem ver o campo deste
negócio é muito mais vasto e hoje em dia
também com uma câmera reflex acoplar um
telescópio e com um terço do tempo é
possível registar todo este trabalho
de uma grande missão me formei em
hidrogênio alfa e no fundo é um berço
araque que nash também estrelas mas a
revelar os primeiros registros não foram
feitos em fotografia foram sim fighters
lápis usando a arte
neste caso traria e teve galileu galilei
quando observou pela primeira vez o
planeta júpiter e esta imagem seria
muito idêntica àquela visão que eu tenho
fé se quando os coppio rudimentar e pra
ter uma lei qualquer um se corre hoje em
dia comprar uma grande superfície
comercial como o livro por exemplo
trilha melhor qualidade de imagem do que
aquela que o motivo no entanto eu
conseguiu ainda assim a observar e
estudar e é toda aquela dinâmica das
luas a volta de júpiter que cada dia
mudava neste caso a imagem era muito
idêntica a esta que eu tenha acesso como
vocês podem ver que seria um disco o
disco do planeta ea volta às ruas
as quatro principais ruas mais visíveis
e o game metros calixto europa mas
galileu galilei não foi o único
também é correr e é a observação do
planeta júpiter infelizmente despertou o
interesse de todas as tropas e
astrónomos amadores também e agora
imaginem como as coisas evoluíram em
pouco menos de 120 talvez 120 anos foi
possível por exemplo como época captar o
planeta júpiter com grande detalhe essa
foto com a sexta feira foi captada por
um astrônomo amador português um pau
casquinha que com a sua habilidade e
arte conseguiu registar todo este
torna-se difícil planeta júpiter e
realmente você consegue ver as listas
conseguem ver a grande mancha vermelha
que no fundo é uma tempestade gigantesca
onda que a bola entrou à terra
integralmente e o time consegue hoje em
dia como câmera que foi usada aqui muito
próximo é porque é realmente muito
próximo daquilo que os coppio água
conseguir captar imagens estão vendo
vosso lado direito é exatamente do avô e
como vem é muito positiva mas no fundo é
também o binário da 20 os olhos sua arte
para 500 anos atrás sensivelmente
escrever um final muito interessante
que ocorre na lua que era o chamado
ordinário no fundo é algo que ocorre
quando a lua está na fase crescente logo
a seguir alguma nova e onde é possível
ver é visualmente dá a sensação que nós
temos a ver uma possível cheia como
podem ver nessa filosofia mas não está
cheia
no fundo é que o que nós conseguimos ver
é uma projeção da luz refletida pela
terra não é suficiente e da lua se
encontra a sombra e portanto assim torna
se visível aquela imagem
chama-se morte angolano e falou que
realmente a paixão dos astros da paixão
de fotografar e um dos objetos mais
fotografados é sem dúvida a lua é capaz
de mostrar todas as carteiras de todos
os estádios mas também de ver essa
evolução tecnológica
hoje em dia é possível captar grandes
eventos que duraram por exemplo horas
durou a noite toda não importá los e e
compactas compactadores num pequeno time
edson é possível ver toda esta dinâmica
é que ocorre durante a noite
na esfera flash mas preparem bem não é o
céu corda é a terra é um planeta terra
tira e agora imaginem que graças a esta
tecnologia que permita hoje em dia ter
essa pressão e conseguiu compactar assim
o tempo e mostrar em poucos segundos ao
que deveria ocorrer durante muito tempo
e muito distantes vocês virem por
exemplo que estou realmente o planeta
terra aponta para um sítio espaço aponta
para lutar é que ela que calcula que
seja mais conhecidas para todas as
estrelas mas não é de forma alguma a
mais luminosa é mais evidente é a forma
de nós conseguimos encontrar neste caso
vocês vão ver uma seqüência animada onde
conseguimos ver todo este forte estudos
em torno de uma estrela é preenchimento
pontual que extrapolar aquela que mais
tem enviado no último milênio está
enviado à em direção ao norte
esta fotografia somente permite uma
uma apreciação muito interessante
imaginem que há muitos anos atrás há
centenas de anos quando o homem não
tinha certeza se o planeta terra era
redonda e teve que sair por mares nunca
dantes navegados para tentar ver e
tentar enviar são dez passos para tentar
fotografar a terra à vista de fora
uma simples imagem destas tivesse
possível registar há centenas de anos
atrás essa curvatura das estrelas
demonstra exatamente isso que nós
estamos num bonito é redondo
agora quando o dia quando nesse caso a
noite quando anoitece o dispõe e é
possível ver um final que ocorre na
terra que a projeção da terra neste caso
esta faixa escura azul acima do
horizonte de projeção do planeta sombra
da terra no céu
astrônomos profissionais que estudam
realmente levam à astronomia mais longe
ainda com grandes telescópios que só
hoje a tecnologia permite ter acesso a
estudar e vários comprimentos de ondas é
o hidrogênio alfas a ultra violeta e nos
raios gama por exemplo como estetoscópio
que vocês vão ver está em web foi
captado em la palma é um grande copo que
é uma dica e que isto realmente essas
explosões de raios gama que ocorrem em
ver que esta que não se conhecia e tudo
isso é possível graças a essa tecnologia
quando a noite termina quando lia nas
continua nossa exploração continuar
nossa capacidade de explorar ele chegar
ainda mais o céu de fotografar e
continua também a grande vantagem porque
no fundo esta evolução tecnológica é não
abrange os profissionais os astrônomos
profissionais mas também é partilhada e
chega todos os astrônomos amadores
aquilo que realmente fazem isso por pura
paixão
no fundo esta imagem vai resolver é uma
imagem do sol foi também ela é captada
constroem
esse é o pedro rei e vocês podem ver os
filamentos do sol podem ver tudo está
ali que é possível é preciso ensinar na
cromosfera tanto né na atmosfera do sol
em sua superfície e e e é bom perceber
por exemplo que as coisas evoluíram de
uma maneira que hoje em dia graças a
esta mesma evolução tecnológica
nós conseguimos por exemplo é estudar é
a actividade destas regiões que têm suas
chamadas zonas ativas aquelas manchas
pretas que vocês conseguem ver aqui
a imagem é muito interessante perceber
que isto dessas regiões é permite
perceber quando existem portugueses têm
aquela projeção daquelas chamas no link
o usuário perceber quando vai ocorrer
por exemplo uma cm é uma ejeção de massa
coronal quando acontece isso e as
chamadas aquelas tem estado soares é nós
aqui na terra graças à tecnologia graças
é o estudo do solo e graças ao facto de
termos sondas no espaço permitem captar
imagens e monitorizar a cada momento
o sol nós conseguimos com 72 horas de
antecedência perceber quando vai ocorrer
um dos espetáculos mais fantásticas que
o ser humano pode assistir aqui dentro
do planeta terra que é amor árvore ao
esta imagem que vocês vão ver um time é
porque está de licença especial
agora parem comum quando as partículas
carregadas de saulo atingem 72 horas
pois é a nossa atmosfera e que o efeito
é aquela interação com nosso campo
eletromagnético provoca toda aquela
atividade é realmente graças a esta
inovação tecnológica que nós conseguimos
chegar a este ponto
e como é que será o extra o nosso
presépio portugal vista do espaço
é realmente fantástica a imagem
visualmente pelo menos
mas reparem que esta é talvez a parte
triste realidade para chegar a este
estado evolução é que vamos poder
treinar outras coisas
se vocês virem a esta luz toda pode ser
fantástica vista do espaço para ter um
ponto de vista artístico muito
interessante mas no fundo pra nós que
temos aqui na terra e pedras ter acesso
ao seu
jacinto passado conseguiu ver e precisa
assinar uns eu realmente não é afetado
pela poluição luminosa e está repleto de
estrelas vi que nos permite ter acesso á
a visualização da nossa própria galáxia
neste caso a via láctea é essa imagens
captadas na nossa reserva dark sky
alqueva que foi o primeiro reserva do
mundo certificada como estar lá editores
ensina como vocês poderão ver aquela
imagem vinha aquela poluição luminosa
situação realmente próximo da costa
norte muito localizada na zona de lisboa
mas foi mais para o interior e encontrou
então a tal zona região do alqueva onde
vista a 0 e um dossel da atividade
consegue ser preservado
isso que vocês estão vendo um é uma
imagem também ela quer falar tanto esta
como anterior e onde é possível ver que
o braço via láctea toda aquela região
repleta de gases no bosa deixamos
estrelas é também possível ver que este
nome
isso vocês vão ver é o chamado é igual
que embora não se trata de uma hora e no
fundo é o limite e se fotoquímica da
própria atmosfera está presente por toda
a terra vista do espaço vocês tiveram
prisão temporária nossa atmosfera muito
clean é uma pequena faixa em volta da
terra é diria uma faixa segurada que nos
proteja todos mas essa clínica faça
vistas do espaço tem cinco verde um ver
paulo de presente a volta é realmente
esse é igual a 15 pés e não ser um céu
realmente negro escuro como os
astronautas conseguem ver por exemplo da
estação espacial internacional e
tecnologia permite realmente também por
exemplo captar um chamado ou cai uma
imagem que consegue cobrir integralmente
o céu é 360 graus
vocês vão ver um time lapse um tablet de
astrónomos de fotógrafos de apaixonados
que fazem isto apenas por
prazer pelo prazer de partilhar um
universo céu e no fundo é também essa a
mensagem que eu queria passar que
arrasam auri do progresso deve vencer é
em prol da humanidade
lembre-se que nós estamos portanto
perante uma janela aberta universo uma
janela aberta sem fronteiras barreiras é
entendimento da nossa etnia religião dá
voz a opção política
perdemos todos o mesmo céu sem
fronteiras ou limites
esta sim deve ser a cada hora do
progresso evoluir em prol da humanidade
obrigado a todos